50 and magnus says no i don't need to  worry about the king it's perfectly okay  and now the big threat is just to attack  the pawn on f2  yeah now now your king is probably  totally safe right and the white bishop  is just passive  um simon g5 is always a good move and  it's always a good move whenever you can  play as black you've got a good position  so  this one the white bishop cannot capture  this pawn because then you lose defense  of the key f2 square and black trades  rooks and wins  so do we have a result we have a result  wow it's uh over a win for magnus  carlsen in game four as well he ends up  winning the match against hans nevan  some  words being exchanged by the two and we  see some smiles as well we like that  sportsmanship  and uh magnus carlsen second day in a  row he wins the match in the rapid  portion to take all three points it's  zero points today as well for hans  niemann but he did win one game against  the world champion